in a new terror alert the homeland
security department warns about the
persistent threat from anti-government
extremists it says the deadly assault on
the capitol left those groups quote
emboldened and capable of new violence
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge is tracking the
potential threat
catherine good morning michelle good
morning while cbs news has learned
homeland security does not have specific
credible intelligence about flooding the
bulletin warns more violence is possible
against
elected officials and government
buildings
a rare bulletin from homeland security
the warning is stark
describing a heightened threat
environment from domestic violent
extremist groups
that may be emboldened by the successful
breach of the u.s
capitol what is it about the breach
january 6
that has emboldened these groups those
who are supporters of
those insurrectionists saw the
saw the photos saw the videos that was
all over social media
of them the fact that they achieved that
is
an inspiration to those of their
followers who weren't there
the warning says groups are motivated by
the 2020 election results
perceived grievances fueled by
misinformation as well as anger over
covet 19 restrictions
in california tuesday ian benjamin
rogers was charged with possession of
five pipe bombs
investigators found 49 firearms and
allege he discussed attacking democrats
and recovered this card which reads
white privilege and
trumps everything the alert comes as the
federal right investigation hits a new
milestone
with more than 400 open case files
dennis sidorsky who wore
an american supremacist hoodie is
charged with violent entry
and disorderly conduct on capitol
grounds
and expanded charges were filed against
thomas caldwell
donovan crowl and jessica watkins three
alleged members of a paramilitary group
the oath keepers for trying to plan an
operation to interfere with the
electoral college certification
the indictment says their coordination
began as early as november
if you had asked me when this my journey
started
if we would ever have this sort of a
bulletin
a threat from domestic from our own
people
inside our own country i wouldn't have
believed it
and cbs news has learned a bipartisan
group of 32 house lawmakers is asking
congressional leadership
to use their office allowances for more
personal security in their home district
where they don't have capital police
protection citing the increased threat
anthony
catherine thank you